Peppa
okay you know what you know I'm a show
Pony wait why do I hear music
because music playing I do too shit
great time
okay it's very subtle hey how you doing
folks here we are what's this thing
called
it's called what the fuck with the
conversation begins it's Garth Brooks oh
come on I like uh Riley Gaines no Clint
Black what's his name doesn't he have an
alter ego Chris Gaines
yeah
write about everything women are dumb
it's right here oh
come on hopefully I don't have a kid
coming
Jesus
man that was wild
that I have a strap on it so that I
won't lose it yeah that was perfect
and the one time I was like I'm not
gonna put the strap on Mark's gonna
think I'm such a dork if I put on my
strap and then my lady has one of those
she loves a strap-on yeah
okay let me just turn this off so that
we're not listening to Alanis Morissette
during the entire show so all right good
how'd it go what you good I'm good yeah
it's a dream I took a nap in his car on
the way here it's been a whirlwind oh
you can sleep in the car can't you not
sleep at night in your own bed I never
thought I could but I we really went
hard last night and drank and then we
got up early and did all these shows
these pods so I needed a nap I know okay
so tell me so you're back drinking again
I never stopped didn't you take some
time off it was like a two-day event I
took off I saw my folks but uh yeah I
drink quite a bit I and I'm in La I see
all the friends I catch up the drinks
are free Sam tripoli's handing you drugs
oh dude I one time did Sam Champion the
show I saw you there last night oh yeah
right and um there was like a bucket of
like cell certs you know and there's so
many seltzers these days right and I
drank I was so thirsty and I drank like
two of them and it was like 80
milligrams THC oh no it was like a THC
I'm like shouldn't there be label
something and anyway wow anything in
that green room on Sam Tripoli night has
weed in it don't touch it yeah I missed
a pitch meeting I flew here for a pitch
meeting and Sam's like hey if you're in
town I'm like all right I'll do his show
the night before then I'm going to bed
and I'm doing this big pitch I missed
all of them because I was too high oh my
agent yelled at me he's like you're
gonna get your ass up you got Netflix
you got Hulu you got this and I was like
I can't do it I was hugging the chair I
remember hugging it because I thought I
was sliding off the planet that was so
high huge mistake are you a weed guy not
at all yep it just it the bad stuff
kicks up you know what I appreciate I
appreciate a good old-fashioned guy that
drinks an old-fashioned I appreciate
shade an alcohol guy I've noticed I
don't know if you've um felt this in
shows in La since you've been here I
noticed people are coming to comedy
shows on weed into I'm like I don't need
you forgiving your ancestors micro
dosing mushrooms during a comedy show I
want a little tequila a little vodka I
want a little anger yeah a little you
know you're pissed off with me I don't
want you like cozying up to your
boyfriend on Indica I'm with you I heard
you yell at the crowd last night you
fucking Indica bitches or whatever that
was good you need it because it makes
you too cozy and then you laugh like two
seconds later
I can tell you guys are enjoying it yeah
but I can also tell your face is
paralyzed right okay that might be the
boat docks but yeah
but I know what you mean it's too slow
you need a little toxicity a little
anger a little Venom yeah and I think
that like tequila whiskey gin kind of
brings that out and people like yeah
let's fight for free speech and watch
this comedian trans is weird yeah you
know but yeah when they're high it's too
lovey-dovey yeah yeah whereas when
people drink alcohol they're like wait I
need to DM that trans girl I forgot yeah
now we're all getting along so I like I
like that you just like you're like I'm
gonna just stick with alcohol yeah yeah
well there's something weird about
alcohol where you feel so great but you
pay for it yeah weed I don't think you
have that and so you gotta really like
to drink because you know you're gonna
be in Hell the next day and really it's
like it's an in the moment thing what is
the least amount of Hell hangover
because I had a I I basically saying I
got sober sounds weird I basically just
stopped smoking with I had a bit of the
weed problems oh really yeah that was
kind of the thing I know everyone thinks
I was on like fentanyl or something but
I just started smoking weed during the
pandemic and if so funny because my I
never did drugs until in my life no my I
come from alcoholics and usually when
you're the child of you end up being the
caretaker right you get addicted to
Perfection and control and you know as
you can tell I'm addicted to Perfection
I know where my phone is at all times
um and work and I had the food stuff I
had the relationship stuff you know and
the relationship stuff is kind of they
say boils down to like a gambling
addiction whoa you're like this hasn't
gone well the last four nights but like
it did two months ago maybe tonight's
the night you know fascinating yeah and
say with coming in her that's a gamble
that's or not wearing a condom big
gamble yeah no trust me I and I've lost
that one
um I always put on blood and I
um and so I never had that and I was so
ambitious like starting as a comic and I
also really you know took to heart not
that everyone didn't but when I first
started comedy Mitch Hedberg died yep
and I that like broke me like I was
looked up to him so much and just the
idea that someone could die that young
and my brain was always like oh I'm the
person that would take it that far right
I'm the person that wouldn't be able to
just like casually do heroin on holidays
yeah like you know and then when Greg
Geraldo died yeah that was a bummer was
like huh the smartest funniest best and
he had been sober when it happened and
it was kind of like I know that I could
because by that point I was like I know
I could do drugs if I wanted but I can't
rely on other people's like stash being
shady yeah totally you know what I mean
well I'm the wrong guy to talk to is
I'll I take drugs from fans which is a
huge mistake don't do that somebody said
somebody gave me money by the way is
that a fan or is that a phone yeah good
question that's true but I guess
somebody gave me Molly and it I did it
with my lady and it turned out to be
crack
yeah we did at the Louvre in Paris so
I'm looking at the Mona Lisa on Crack by
the way that is the only time I feel
like that is worth waiting in line for
her like whenever I watch this crowd of
people looking at the Mona Lisa I'm like
are you guys on crack this isn't that
entertaining it's so tiny well you know
why the Mona Lisa is famous because it
got stolen ah and then when they got it
back I was like we got to go see it so
it got all this buzz it was almost like
getting canceled it got Buzz for not the
talent of the painting because it's not
that great of a painting yeah that it
got stolen so all the newspapers were
going crazy and then when they got it
back people like we gotta go see it whoa
I also feel like it was like she was
like the first porn star or something it
was like you'd have to look at paintings
back then because remember men are
always like look at her eyes are so
enigmatic it's like not real is this
just all you guys really had well that
was nude paintings though yeah that's
true but uh yeah but there's something
about that's true sometimes I'm looking
at uh these hot ladies on Instagram more
than porn because there's a little yoga
pant or something going on Sebastian
would say they wrapped the gift oh I
remember when I was in Beirut uh with
Tom Papa and we I know excuse me
what are you guys doing there did you
see action and uh we went into a mosque
and I walked in and this woman ran up to
me you know like pulled me aside because
I had to wear like the garments the
headgear the bird I don't think it was
technically a burka the heat job I might
be a good job yes I think burka is like
the al-Qaeda right like beekeeper thing
yes this is just like the head scarf and
whatever and I put it on and I'm walking
around and he was like there is
something that is so hot about the fact
that I can't see any of your skin is
that a compliment no
he could still see my personality so
something must have been knowing him but
the eyes they pierce because they
literally pop but he was like there's
something about the mystery right of it
I don't know I think since we're able to
see naked people whenever we want all
the time there's something hot about
mystery now I think you're right yes I
think right it's like we said in the
kitchen it goes full circle it's like
we're back on podcast that's just radio
we went back to radio yes we did I think
there's something to be said for yeah
being able to imagine what's going on
and just hear the hear it and not be
looking at it and be distracted about
like what is she wearing why does she
look like that like your imagination is
going to do such better things totally
and what is actually there like remember
that movie Signs yeah I remember that
movie Signs Mel Gibson
um who by the way has 18 movies in
production no truly 18. do you hate and
Mel really the guy's Unstoppable yeah
well you know if you're good you're good
by the way Amber Heard has a movie
coming out well yeah blondes and
anti-semites are really having a moment
and I'm back it's all back
yeah wait oh Mel Gibson no no wait that
was a Mel Gibson he was in it yeah okay
he was the dead and there was a um alien
yeah remember and they were being
haunted or whatever by aliens and you
didn't see the alien until like 10
minutes before the movies oh that's
better I was scared shitless because you
would see like a knife out of the door
yeah it's like and then you saw the
alien and you're like what I know that's
corny ass what is that that's why I
don't take my dick out till way later in
the date because I don't want to ruin it
it's not it's ugly wait what's crack
like it sucks I hated it well I also ate
it you're supposed to smoke it yeah so I
ate the cracks I thought it was Molly so
I just ate it and swallowed it and I was
shitting water I was sweating I was
cracked out I was like shaky and uh
nervous and paranoid so I was in the
Louvre like biting my nails I was in the
toilet the whole time it was wild never
again we're going to in a second and
listen to boozy talk about crack oh
there you go have you seen this no he
talks about why crack is so much better
than fentanyl oh it is so funny dude
damn um okay so how was her experience
on crack same thing we both hated it and
we're just shaking we're all soaked in
sweat we had to leave
uh how did you know it was crap like how
did I mean
yeah and somebody's like I think that
was cracked yeah
it said crack
wait so this was a fan she said it was
or he said it was Molly yeah he's like I
got some Molly for and he did like the
handoff shake you know and I feel like
the way drugs are given to you tells you
whether you should take them or not hand
off is bad yeah this cupping thing is
bad was it in plastic it was in shitty
cellophane plastic like a cigarette pack
Bad News Bears man like when someone
comes up to me at a show it's like
here's a joint and it's just like not
wrapped in anything it's just out I'm
like I feel like this is safe when
someone tries to like slip something in
my back pocket a meet and greet I'm like
yeah totally the way you're doing it
makes me think I should not put this in
my body I did fentanyl
um
because of your Instagram live probably
I think that's what did it oh really
well there was some new today wasn't
there a uh check out my my bathing with
the underwear remember that pandemic
yeah whatever you want to play any your
legs were in the air and you were
showing us your panties oh that was on
the way to Vegas yeah I was dead so
wrong
you guys know about liquid death here on
the podcast because you see it's always
on the desk it's always around the
guests are always drinking it I'm
obsessed I think it's hilarious to drink
liquid death in public because a lot of
people think I'm drinking alcohol like
it looks like a beer kind of and it's
sort of funny to watch people sweat it
out
because like people I'll like be
drinking and I'll see people clock it
we'll keep awkwardly talking and then
finally
it's okay what is that and I'm like it's
liquid death it's like oh God it's just
water okay it's like so funny to be
drinking this pregnant and watch how
much people think it's alcohol and I'm
like wait a second so before I was
pregnant people just thought I was like
fully on the sauce like all day
but I love it I I have to tell people
I'm like you guys I am pregnant thanks
so much for the vote of confidence uh my
favorite part of this is that it doesn't
look like a dorky water you know you've
seen these on all of our podcasts liquid
death you've seen it on birds Bert and
Tom all of it it looks like a beer but
it's not a beer okay we don't drink beer
during our podcast we keep whiskey
hidden in rolls of toilet paper like
adults okay I get so much attention when
I have my liquid death on me which is
the most important thing to me about
water
I've been drinking liquid death water
for years and look how hydrated I am I
mean look at me not I'm not drinking out
of that nasty plastic bottles anymore
I've noticed a difference honestly I'm
not drinking out especially being
pregnant I'm definitely not drinking out
of that nasty plastic chock full of
phthalates that shrinks babies tanks
no sir not this guy my baby's gonna have
the biggest taint on the Block thanks
liquid death I love liquid death because
they kill exactly zero Turtles but
they're infinitely recyclable cans okay
you know plastic bottles aren't even
recyclable that was a whole scam Michael
schellenberger just did a speech about
this they get sent to landfills
which egg on my face I've broken up with
so many guys and got in so many fights
with them for not recycling
and now I have to tell my exes they were
right this whole time
what's worse than that liquid death also
donates a portion of the profits uh uh
from every canceled to help kill plastic
pollution so the orcas aren't hitting
our boats no Siri
um in addition to water they now have my
favorite drink okay so let me just show
you all the drinks that I'm obsessed
with okay this one is severed lime this
is the one that like basically tastes
just like a ginger ale kind of like a
Sprite I'm really obsessed with this I
have all of them here but my new
obsession because I can't drink coffee
because it's too acidic and I don't
think my baby should be addicted to
coffee when it comes out it's going to
be addicted to plenty things but maybe
not coffee it's armless Palmer look at
this iced tea plus Agave so no trash
sweeteners plus vitamins it's got
vitamins in it you guys it has B12
and B6
what more could you want I drink this
every morning I'm not even kidding look
how good
armless Palmer and it's hilarious to
boot you can find liquid deaths healthy
beverage on Amazon or at a real a real a
real one a real grocery store or a
realtor a retailer a retailer near you
and good for you listeners get 20 off
their first liquid death apparel
purchase first of all liquid death
apparel is so cute I'm gonna hold up
this t-shirt can you see it hold on do
you see how cute that is and then look
at the back
how cute is that okay my handyman who is
also like has impeccable tastes as a
designer reached out to me he's like can
you help me get that liquid death shirt
like people are all about this so and
the quality is like amazing look how
good this shirt is I'm I'm pretty
obsessed with their mercs there's a
sweatsuit that I wear constantly so 20
off your first liquid death apparel
purchase available at liquiddeath.com
Whitney exclusions May apply
liquidath.com Whitney
we were going to Vegas me Chelsea Lynn
you know trailers Tammy Chelsea yeah
they bring out the best of me and the
words to me I wish that we didn't well
your hair was blue we didn't know what
was going on what when you have I think
it was pink at that oh Pink by the time
it got to like purple it was I really at
that point it's like code red yeah
people started just showing up at my
house you're like just checking on you
yeah this one just make sure you were
okay right yeah no but we'll get to that
because I did have to quit weed actually
um in January December and January is
where it got out of hand with wheat but
we'll talk about that okay all right
yeah I had to stop too because I was
taking it to sleep it helps me sleep
and uh I kept having like the recall
issues and my friend was like oh I
smoked a ton in high school I totally
lost my memory so you better stop and I
just quit that day see that's exactly
except my rock bottom was I felt like I
wasn't as quick on stage it wasn't as
quick and podcasts yeah and I got
because so many people go oh you smoke
weed to like expand your mind it makes
you so creative you're gonna like I
think of such great jokes on we if
that's your experience like that's
awesome I'm so happy for you but like I
would smoke weed have like a journal
that I would like fall asleep and like
write like notes down like just like I'm
just gonna do free association of my
thoughts and like ah such a great
premise like oh this is genius I'd wake
up the next morning or be like men and
women are different
it's not profound like I felt like when
I was smoking weed I thought I was so
much more interesting than I was yeah
and I was like this is dangerous and
look yeah I do think it's good for some
people like like a Luis Gomez will get
high and he's just chilled he Nails it
with that yeah so it's it's a
personality thing like I've taken
Adderall and bouncing off the walls some
people take an Adderall and they're calm
because they prescribed it to sleep no
way that's hilarious yeah I mean I don't
you know that's like taking a Viagra to
get your boner to go down I've never
heard of it to sleep well because I
guess if you actually do have ADD it's
supposed to calm your brain down but I
had the it was the um what's it called
um riddle time release oh right the time
release No but a friend of mine uh gave
me a rhythm once when I was writing a
book and it was I liked it so much I was
like I could never do this again it
feels good it's euphoric and you're
you're firing in all cylinders totally
totally I mean I like you know my lips
were white after two hours but other
than that like it was pretty great you
know because you're like I haven't drank
water in two days this can't be great
but it would jerk off a lot I was always
so horny oh really yeah yeah just it was
like they say meth does that too you
just like start jerking off a ton and
watching porn oh yeah so you're taking
apart a vacuum cleaner then you jerk it
and you go back to the vacuum cleaner
you use the vacuum cleaner to suck your
dick off
um that's wild and then okay so so I
also think shit starts to happen where
you're mixing stuff you're like I'm
gonna have a drink and then I'm gonna or
you know so for me taking weed to sleep
I think also one of the biggest gets
problems with that was I wasn't having
dreams I know this is dorky a woman
needs to talk about her dreams
um but I found myself I would just go to
sleep wake up in the same position and
not dream and I feel like that's where
we process a lot of our anxieties and a
lot of our fears and it's where you like
you know just like release and expunge a
lot of old anxiety and I found myself
when I wasn't smoking weed being more
and more anxious about like things I
wasn't normally anxious about and then
my tolerance for discomfort went so down
I found myself being such an immature
baby like I remember one time I was like
opening um like an alpha brain or
something and um which is the most fun
thing to me when you start doing drugs
you then start getting like healthier in
other ways I was like well my memory's
going so I should probably do Alpha
Brain or just stop smoking weed you
idiot and after the crack I went keto
you know just Eve let it out and so I um
was like trying you know when there's
like a plastic around a thing you have
to open it's just like annoying and
you're just like like and I tried like
three times to get off fuck this right
and I was like if that's how fast I'll
not
open a vitamin bottle yeah because I'm
like all of a sudden my it's not my
attention my patience yeah getting
really short well good good for you to
catch that because most people just go
that way I had to look through a lot of
YouTube comments
you know people let me know you know
right well be careful with those
comments those are vicious yeah yeah
you're so right about the processing
things because everybody's like I need
to be happy I'm so unhappy let me take a
pill but like you're supposed to be
unhappy every now and then you need
contrast yeah it can't all be highs
exactly I mean it's like in program you
know they say that alcoholics are the
only people that think they should be
having fun all the time and when you're
sort of like yeah it's not we don't
celebrate every night yeah you know so I
found myself being like ah okay I've had
a hard day I mean my mom died and I
really took that as like uh I don't need
to feel I don't want to feel this pain
yeah it's like you should feel that pain
sure you should be sad and grieve and I
just I didn't want to and then
the other curveball is when we were
working on the only fans Rose to Bert
Kreischer I love all y'all
um not singling anyone out because
everyone did it so I couldn't
um there was a lot of micro dosing
mushrooms ah yes where's
seem to really work for people but also
don't take their word for it right right
everyone's like this has like changed my
life it's really helping me I'm like
well you did show up three hours later
so I your account of it is you're like I
don't even care that I'm late right
that's how much I accept what's going on
and like this is just the way the
traffic is going today and I'm just
gonna be my authentic self that's
exactly I got your jokes in half the
words were misspelled yeah like like I
just wrote all these jokes and like
didn't criticize myself like maybe you
should there's a kid in your bumper he
just ran over a kid and you're like I
don't care he was meant to die yeah
exactly you know so I was like okay let
me try this like I'm going through grief
whatever and the biggest problem with it
I feel like is that it was micro dose
mushrooms it which by the way micro dose
it can turn macro really fast yeah so
true if the micro dose tells you well
that dose didn't work it's just the tip
of drugs you know I'll just put the tip
in before you know what your balls deep
in an asshole so yeah and I know what
you mean it's exactly and then it's
chocolate bars so right it's unclear
whether I'm addicted to mushrooms or I'm
just a chocoholic I'm not sure but I
just would be like these are delicious
and I was just like pot and then I'd be
like oh wait that's drugs yeah well have
you heard the lobster Theory no I can't
remember who said some famous brilliant
physicist guy whatever he said lobsters
you know they have the shell then they
have the gooey internal veiny part yeah
so the gooey internal veiny part keeps
growing and it butts up against the
shell and it hurts so they have to go
hide under a rock shed the shell which
is very painful and then build a new
shell and then they come back out and
then you know a few years go by they
have to shed the shell again because
they keep growing and the point is it
takes like five of those to become a
full-size Lobster but if it was humans
we would just take a pill every time you
hurt and you wouldn't grow whoa so you
would just be butting up against the
shell but you wouldn't feel it but you'd
never grow as a lobster and that's what
we do now we just take a pill instead of
dealing with it and process which is
like whack-a-mole yeah it's gonna come
out other ways yeah then you shoot up a
school yeah right you know and I feel
like yeah I've never done thank God and
who knows like
um I've always I was so before like ah
substances are never been my thing
whatever so I'm like you know let's just
stay humble here that I've never the
pills have never been my thing I see
people that are on that shit and it's
like it goes from five milligrams to 50
and oh yeah a month oh yeah it's amazing
what the human liver can take you know
guys like I'm on my 50th volume and
you're like wow yeah I take one I'm out
yeah yeah so I I was I want to say I
don't know what I was on the road like I
don't know a couple years before the
pandemic I would do like Benadryl to
sleep or like those z-quills dude oh
those are good uh the fact that those
are legal is shocking one time I took
those and I fired my lawyer and he was
not my lawyer
it was wild like for some reason well
that's just alcohol right isn't it
NyQuil is just like alcohol right is
that right I figured it was like what's
the thing that makes you fall asleep uh
melatonin it's Sudafed Ambien oh Sudafed
that's well isn't that what you make
method or is that it's a component of it
yeah whoa yeah dude
it's the new thing everyone's into is
Kratom have you done that no I heard
it's bad news and I know a couple people
that like you know they're going through
a rough divorce oh right yeah yeah it's
highly addictive and it's hard to it's
hard to kick but it's like natural isn't
it that's right so are mushrooms that's
part of what got me dude I was like this
comes from the earth like the Earth
wouldn't want me to derail my life right
or ruin any relationships like these are
mushrooms like we're both made out of
the same thing and you're like no no no
what's that shit in uh oh fuck it was in
Breaking Bad ricin what's that rice is a
poison you can kill people with ricin
and Bryson is a poison yeah poison found
naturally and Castor beans yes natural
Castor beans are chewed and swallowed
they release so this is like how women
like poison their wives yeah yeah yeah
look that happens too
2023 baby that's like remember Norms do
you see Norm special that he did over
the pandemic I'm gonna butcher this of
course Norm's you know my favorite
favorite and um when he would say like
so there was this weather man or woman
like everything it made me laugh so hard
because I also castor oil when you are
trying to give birth and can't
apparently if you put on Castor oil it
will induce birth whoa can be a form of
powder mist or pellet or it can be
dissolved in water or weak acid I only
learned from Breaking Bad they killed a
guy with racing okay let's see if I can
do this without it being a total mess
this is boozy talking about
okay but you actually made an
interesting statement
you tell people to stop taking Fentanyl
and go back to crack crack
I'm promoting it
fitting all killing all the junkers
who've been junkies I'm doing this
killing the jungles who've been youngest
for
forever yes soon as they hit it they did
right crackhead this nigga shoot threes
the nigga shoot basketball this nigga
this nigga Run Run 100 miles this nigga
get sane this nigga fix your car motor
I've been doing this for 20 years this
motherfucker still running around the
neighborhood when have you ever heard
crackheads hitting the pipe and dying
the first time never never just spent
all shit is different I would much
rather crack he's not wrong I would much
rather much rather crack you said I've
been seeing my crackhead people for 30
years
sitting all two times
he's gone you never see him again right
right I promote crack before Vietnam I'm
sorry right and you know something then
crackhead bro they can do anything yeah
we see those crackhead couples that have
been together for like 15 years they can
do anything they're still smoking crack
and they're still together they can do
anything bro crack your head bro
whatever was in crack they gave them a
real Powers did you ever see the video
of the crackhead with the kangaroo
no I ain't see
hold on a second that's a funny sentence
shit that she didn't kill so many people
in Baton Rouge bro like it's sad bro
like
look at this
so ridiculous so how is how it's exactly
right when they're a mayor Marion Barry
was on crack I'm from DC we voted for
him to be re-elected look at that uh
Whitney Houston crackhead you know yeah
so he's got a point yeah that I mean
it's you know I ideally these aren't
your two choices in life but yes but you
did fentanyl how did that go and did you
do it on purpose no I I thought it was a
Xanax and it had fentanyl in it and I
slept for like 42 hours was this
something that you got from I couldn't
sleep so I had this guy who opened for
me in San Antonio and I said hey man if
you can get some Xanax I just got to go
to bed I haven't slept in days and he
was like I got you man I'm an addict I
can get anything you want and he got
some like heavy duty shit and I didn't
know it was stepped on and I slept I
missed the gigs slept through the night
my opener my other opener had to come
wake me up they had taken me out of my
hotel room because I ran over time and
they just pulled me into the lobby and
like packed my bags and just in the
lobby of a Red Roof Inn and uh
eventually my my opener came and found
me and he was like walking me around he
said my feet were just dragging it's
like Weekend at Bernie's totally I was
joking
and uh eventually he's like maybe I'll
get an IV so he got me an IV and that
like woke me up
like a Burt Chrysler Dave Chappelle
drunk guy IV and that woke me up and I
was like coming to and I was wonky I I
filmed all of it I was like ah I looked
like you
like me on the way to Vegas but yeah it
was crazy but then I like came too and
uh got my shit together oh it took about
a day to like re recoup
it was wild did you and you just knew it
was fentanyl because that's what the the
lady said she was like a nurse and she's
like this is a fentanyl I've seen this
she's like you're lucky to be alive I'm
terrifying terrifying so stay off drugs
kids don't take drugs from doctors if
you're or not I don't know yeah gotta
get to Natural gotta figure out why I
can't sleep did you ever
um uh there's this the theory called the
night watcher Theory I think I have the
book downstairs about how
in tribal times they don't call me ho
Rogan for nothing
um that back in the day like there were
people that had to stay up at night
while everyone else slept right so it
was your job to you know look here for
tigers and you know protect the tribe
basically and those people always were
basically nocturnal they would breed
with them and they essentially became
nocturnal and so they say some of us
just descend from night Watchers and we
just kind of naturally when the Sun goes
down like we're hyper Vigilant and we're
awake wow that makes a lot of sense the
sun goes down I'm up up because everyone
else is in bed and I like it I feel
alone and I feel like I can't do my shit
and then I was like growing up and now
call a column it's like ACA 101 is like
that when things get dark that's when
you have to be right you know basically
on alert my house people are breaking in
all the time so I was always up at night
I don't really know why you can't sleep
yeah I guess so I never thought about
that yeah so but I had to do like EMDR
around that kind of stuff and I also
started listening to whale sounds
exactly what it said oh sorry uh album
all right I feel like those jokes are
open now because she came out as a meme
dude I mean it it's an interesting one
it's fun I like when a counselor or not
a cancer but like a pro this and pro
that yeah actually is full of shit and
we catch them and also like she's the
one that empowered these girls to think
they were queens that deserved respect
totally with her own you know what I
mean don't tell all all women are Queens
like princesses maybe do they have the
Queens already I know it's a leap it's
like the guy who's like super homophobic
and he's blowing dudes behind the shed
yes right you need all of them yeah yeah
usually usually remember all those
Republicans that were busted in the
airport
on the on the floor with the shoe yeah
yeah that was there which is gay enough
that you're tap dancing you know like
action me are your subscriptions
draining your wallet the average person
has around 12 paid subscriptions and
they might not even remember subscribing
to all that what a hassle if you have no
idea just how much you're spending each
month did you just see me hit myself in
the face by accident you need rocket
money it's this great app it tracks all
of your expenses so you know exactly
where your money is going did you know
eighty percent of people have
subscriptions that they've forgotten
about huh yeah we need to make weed
illegal again but the point is think of
how many free trials you subscribe to
that you probably never canceled that's
why I'm such a big fan of Rocket money
I'm talking to you fan Maroon 5 fan club
who got me and got me good charging me
seven dollars for four years rocket
money and I are coming for you I use
rocket money I was paying for two gyms I
didn't know about Google pay Pat I sent
you this email but I was like what is
this it was 2.99 a month but it's still
annoying why do I have zombie accounts
why why am I subscribed to Hulu plus
minus why am I still subscribed to HBO
it's at home box office I don't think
that's been the name of it for like 10
years so I don't know I had all these
other emails I guess I was paying for
that aren't even company like SBC Global
I'm like why do I have a geocities
account it was just a mess the New York
Times I'm paying for the New York Times
that trash rag are you nuts
okay I did some free trial and then they
got me Hook Line and Sinker and I've
been paying for what recipes on how to
make avocado toast we all know how to
make it rocket money scrapes through
your stuff to find all of these sick
criminal companies bleeding you dry I
was spending 280 a month on these
criminals that tricked me it's all
collusion thank you rocket money for
showing them who's boss most people
think they're spending eighty dollars on
their subscriptions when in reality the
number is closer to two hundred dollars
when you're signed up for so many things
like streaming services you used to
watch one show or free trials for
deliveries that you don't use it's easy
to lose track of what you're paying for
with rocket money you can easily cancel
the ones that you don't want with the
Press of a button no more long hold
times or annoying emails with customer
service gross rocket money does all of
the work for you rocking money can even
negotiate lower bills for you this is
amazing by up to 20 all you have to do
is take a picture of your bill rocket
money takes care of the rest why even
get married
why even get a husband if Rock that's
the only point of having them
rocket money is replacing your need to
get patrolled with over three million
users and Counting rocket money
customers have saved an average of 720 a
year genius rocket money is a personal
finance app that finds and cancels your
unwanted subscriptions monitors your
spending and helps you lower your bills
all in one place stop wasting money on
things you don't use cancel your
unwanted subscriptions and manage your
money the easy way by going to
rocketmoney.com Whitney that's
rocketmoney.com
whitneyrocketmoney.com
Whitney but please don't unsubscribe to
the good for you emails
but we don't charge you right
do you have like employees now I should
I don't no I I mean I need an assistant
I fuck up everything I double book I
fuck up a flight I'll book it for the
wrong year you need an assistant just to
get you Xanax
it's just like a sober drug dealer right
um but uh I think that a lot of people
don't understand like of course your
employees aren't your friends whatever I
think it's really hard for us as Comics
It's like because when we have openers
we're friends with them like
legitimately and like we can be
different like levels and it doesn't
feel like hierarchical and we're
genuinely equals totally even though
other people might not perceive us that
way or they might not perceive us that
way but it's like what I think lizzo
really doesn't understand it's like no
one wants to celebrate with you like
they're not celebrating so it's like you
bring your dancers that are making 200 a
show like come to the strip club like
let's celebrate like they're they don't
want to be behind you they don't want to
be in your Instagram story while you're
giving a thousand dollars to a stripper
and answer it like they don't have
anything to celebrate yet like they want
to be back in their hotel room making
their Tick Tock so that they can be you
one day yeah think that sometimes I've
done it where it's like you know I'm
like oh my God I finally have stuff you
know I was treated like such garbage
when I was you know it works for other
people or just like and not even with
the people I open for all the time but
like working on writing staffs and stuff
like that it's like them taking us out
to dinner would have been such a big
deal
we were starving like that would have
been awesome you know to feel like a
human being or feel seen by whatever but
the idea of like these days being like
come let's go party let's go to the
strip club like they don't see it that
way no and I think things have shifted a
little like generationally like I
remember I'm not gonna say who but I
opened for a guy and I didn't know what
to do I'm in the green room and it's
quiet and I'm like so uh how did you how
long you've been doing it he goes we're
not fucking girls we don't have to fake
conversation and I was like okay was it
Wayne Brady because he's pansexual and
he just didn't want to fall in love with
you no no I wish I wish it was at that
level it was way lower Wayne Brady's
famous but no he's a funny guy it was
just like uh but to me I was like oh now
I know yeah it was just like a work it
was a work thing but there was a lot of
that I feel like there was a real
hierarchy then yeah don't you feel like
it was so true like hey don't talk you
can't talk to us also there wasn't Tick
Tock YouTube Instagram where you're like
if this person doesn't like me good
point like this is my only shot of being
seen is going on the road with this
person this is my only shot of working
yes you know like basically like
Headliners were your ticket to getting
stage time 100 now it's weird because
like Headliners book the feature
like clubs used to book a feature
interesting now the headliner books the
feature yeah yeah yeah so for sure it's
kind of negating your point but I think
you're still you still have a good point
thank you
make everybody happy here yeah it's so
interesting because it's like I think of
you like you know I was talking to
someone about this where I was like I
think like pound for pound Norman might
be like the bravest person on podcasts
like just in terms of just in terms of
like your um
a comic
um uh but I realized that when people
call a woman Brave it's a just an insult
um it either means you look old and have
the audacity to go on camera or like
you're willing to be annoying or
something no but I mean like like you'll
go for these like incendiary areas where
I feel like a lot of people would bite
their tongue or a lot of people would
like get sanctimonious or self-righteous
and it makes me jealous sometimes
because I'm like I don't say that or
like cut that yeah and like but yet
you're this person who's like really
cares what people think oh yeah I think
most people are look at Cosby not to
compare myself to Cosby but he's super
pull your pants up speak well family
values and then he's a serial rapist yep
yeah everybody has that weird I'd rather
pretend I'm the serial rapist on camera
and be the good person yeah exactly I do
think it's so that is so true everybody
evens out you know if you go all the way
this way you know you're coming back
that way it's like we've talked about a
couple celebrities in the kitchen who
have that they're like all this online
and then they're actually terrible
people in real life yes and I just I
feel like you know it's interesting
because I I to a fault I think sometimes
over share or like show too much of my
like Shadow Self you know on camera and
stuff I should probably you know but to
me that's always a way of going like I
just don't want to feel like I'm hiding
anything it's like you're only as sick
as your secrets like I never want to
feel like I'm full of shit or like lying
or you know and also it's like a big
part of our job as comedians is to like
say the things no one else will say just
yes just to surprise people exactly and
like I don't even believe what I'm
saying of course I'm joking I don't I
mean I still say retard but on and off
camera yeah I'm sorry like
um but like saying things where you're
like I just said it because no one else
can say it and we all get right oh okay
we're not China and that's the essence
of Comedy like I saw David tell on stage
and he goes what are you doing the guy
goes I work for Nickelodeon he goes no
wonder I'm hard and it's a it's such a
great line and so quick but he's it's
funny because he's not hard crap that's
the joke it wouldn't be yes and then
they go what is he attracted to kids no
no that's why it's funny because also we
have to let people be dumb I guess so
but you can be dumb but don't don't call
me a pedophile because you're dumb yeah
yeah yeah yeah yeah so that's the hard
part but it's just it's inevitable it's
interesting because like did people do
that before there was just no way of
knowing it to you so like people would
leave a rich your prior show and be like
he is of course this but there was just
he would never hear about it 100 and I
think I heard Seth MacFarlane on an
interview once said he he got uh like 79
bags of hate mail like written mail and
he would just throw them in an
incinerator but he counted like I got 79
bags last season from Family Guy and
that's what it is but it's just on a
comment now and also I think that like
for Me Maybe I'm going too hard in the
other direction just to be able to like
get through the day or something
um but think about how much pain you
have to be in to write a letter I know
it's
hilariously
It's like because we all we were talking
about addictions earlier like we all
have had weird addictions like we've all
you know like you know people eat their
hair and you know people eat mattresses
I just I just did a refresher on um
intervention oh great show um and so
some peoples is like the self-righteous
and ignition addiction of like I'm
outraged by this thing you know and I
think there are some people I got in a
fight with
um
a pretty rough fight with somebody and
the interview didn't end up airing
because whoa this person said to me she
was like you know like because you know
we see how comedy is causing violence
oh that's like crazy I was like let me
stop you right there this was like four
months after Chris Rock had been
punching the face on stage for a very
benign joke yeah which by the way you
know he had so many other
sniper ass Savage jokes that's too rough
let's just do the GI Jane yeah you know
he's like let's just go easy on her yeah
and um and then Chappelle had been
attacked to the Hollywood Bowl like uh
Kim Congdon Ariel thrown at her had the
beer thrown at her and there I mean John
caparula had something thrown on him and
Hermosa and Jeffries was punching the
face years ago Dude that is so wild that
video I know but it kind of broke him
yeah yeah and then Joan Dangerfield
Rodney's um uh Widow is a good friend of
mine and she was telling me about how
Rodney used to get beat up after shows
is that right the time yeah it's like
this is just like we have no protection
we have no security
um so I was like let me stop you right
there because comedians are getting
physically assaulted like on stage and
I'm not just talking about the rich ones
that have security and how you know it's
like most of it is ones that are just
like at bar shows yeah in Cincinnati
exactly and what'd she say it got really
awkward really yeah she's like no but
you know what I mean I'm like no no you
just made a statement yes saying that we
are causing violence and she's just read
that somewhere now she's regurgitating
it she doesn't it's such a stupid uh
notion like Bill Burr had that great
point where he's on a Morning Show and
the lady's like don't you think it went
a little far with the priest pedophile
jokes he's like I think the priests went
all too far it's like go to that first
and then come to me because it's also
like if you
um and I I don't know it's the kind of
thing where it's like are you someone
that just feels so helpless about things
you need someone to blame and we're easy
to blame because we'll take blame them
exactly because we're also the kind of
people that go I'm a piece of shit but
we can't do it to the point to our going
oh yeah we cause violence like fuck out
of here dude like it's just I mean did
you have violence at your shows after
the pandemic there were a lot of fist
fights in the audience at my shows but I
think that was more from um the pandemic
like tension oh sure I've had guys come
on stage before but that was
pre-pandemic so it it definitely happens
at Hartford funny ball night a guy come
on stage yeah it got pretty ugly but I
he was like walking up that I kept
kicking him while he was walking up the
stairs because I didn't want him to get
up there and then they finally you know
this the guy had like a wing in his
mouth the security guy oh shit all right
you know no one gives a fuck and uh it
he got he like tackled the guy but it
got pretty close what was there a
certain joke or like could you pinpoint
what you think the he's doing that thing
where he's in the front row with his
friends and they're shitting on me low
like quiet so no one else could hear it
yeah so I just was like I just snapped
you know about 20 minutes in I couldn't
handle it anymore he's like this guy
fucking you fucking suck you're the
worst comic ever you fucking hack and I
kept ignoring it because no one else
could hear it and then I just go fuck
you you piece of shit I just like lost
and I was attacking his appearance and
he was like a schlubby Comic-Con looking
kind of guy and I was like you're
probably a fucking virgin and when I
said virgin he just stood up he was like
that's it in cells don't like being
called version no exactly and everybody
in the back's going why you fuck with
the guy leave him alone because they
didn't hear exactly so it was a tough
spot and then he's coming on stage and
they're like well good for him he got
yelled at for no reason and so now they
all hate me he hates me and I'm like no
you don't understand he was saying shit
and they're like I didn't hear anything
and then now he's coming up the little
stairs and I'm kicking him on the way up
and uh they finally you know went at him
we've been yelling for like five minutes
and they they didn't do anything about
that and then when he started coming up
they tackled him
but I could have taken him he was like a
real nerdy that's not Jonah Hill we're
here to make yuck yucks and make life a
little easier guys and you came to the
show maybe the audiences should do it
again I've changed my mind all together
maybe no gin and tonics it's a good
point it is wild I mean it's I find like
sometimes the hardest to deal with is
girls because you they know you can't
hit them right you know and when girls
are kind of like positive helpful heck
going Nashville I'm talking to you
um
and they're all at their bachelorette
party you know and so um you know and
you like there's nothing you can really
do and then it's like when you're sort
of the underdog you know like back in
the day I don't know and then maybe the
climate has changed you can say like can
someone put a dick in her mouth and it's
like fine now you kind of like can't and
um because women are like equal now
um and uh and It's tricky because you're
in the situation where you're like and I
think
this is our fault but I think the crowd
work videos oh yeah have you noticed a
difference I've heard some Comics have
to go this is the comedy stand-up
portion please stop yelling out I'm like
that's my nightmare they're like I'm
gonna star in this Tick Tock video
exactly I know when someone's wearing
like a cowboy hat yeah a boa yeah a lady
is bad boa's bad when they're facing
away from you you just see the Tiara
twinkling you're like oh I'm fucked like
a dick hat yeah
yeah that's a lot is there anything that
you feel like like any I think you said
you're working on new jokes last night
yeah is there anything
um that you're like working that you
like can't or like isn't working and you
don't know why Story of My Life the
jokes you can't crack and you always
like pull your hair out then one day
you're just taking a dump and you're
like
but that's that's you know it takes time
it takes time to just like haunt you yes
but those are the ones that when you
figure it out they're the best ones are
there any in particular are like
premise-wise or things that you're like
ah because this just happened in the
news this no longer like I was working
on this joke and like I know it's a
dated joke in a lot of ways but I think
that's part of the reason I kind of like
it
um and it's not it's not there yet but I
was trying to do something about
um
like how every time an actress gets
hugged too long we like have to March
and like the world shuts down you know
you know yeah but like no one cares
about boys that were molested in the
Catholic Church like I mean Bill Burgess
brought like no one cares it's kind of
like literally no one cares like right
like and um well Rogan had a similar bit
but I think it's different enough yeah
his was uh it's horrible it happens to
women you guys get assaulted and this
and that but at least when that happens
to you people give a shit yeah yeah my
buddy got raped I'd laugh at him like if
Harvey Weinstein raped him he'd be like
which is so true well I was just trying
to go more of the angle of like how I
think it's because when you hear the
word molested yeah no one really knows
what molested is because like do you
know what I'm saying like when someone's
as molested it's like does that mean
like
you're the priest is like I that's what
I would think like you're he's actually
like like blowing or like having sex
with a butt or something and then if
someone's like no it's just like diddle
just touching balls like no one knows
there's a big spectrum of things that
could be totally and no one can talk
about it because what if I went too far
in the what I thought it was now I'm the
weirdo oh interesting like I was kind of
trying to go like until the word
molested gets more specific yeah we
can't do this because then I might risk
embarrassing myself by right saying
something way grosser than actually it
was or something you know what I'm
saying yeah you don't be the one who's
like oh so you blew your son like no no
I just fondled what yeah no we just like
made out a little yeah you know I don't
know like I just you know so I know I
still don't know what molested actually
means right whether it means the full
shebang or if it's just yeah yeah that
is tough I feel like that with lesbian
sex I don't know is it fingering is it
scissoring is it eating out is it strap
on it's very vague I think it's a lot at
all I think it might be a lot all of
those okay okay yeah so you've you've
fucked a girl right you mentioned that I
have how do you think I got pregnant
yeah so did that involve everything yeah
it kind of involves everything and then
the I mean at least la la women are in
big into the toy scene but like I was
like Carrot Top in there you're like a
prop compact I feel like Santa yeah it's
like I just couldn't do anymore it's
just like I can't I'm not taking on any
new Chargers
um
sex toy Chargers are always like it's
like delicate like they delicately just
kiss each other and then you have to
just like you know um you have to listen
to the toys day that's the only way it
charges my wife has like 800 vibrators
it will be like in the throes of passion
and she's like get the vibrator I open
the drawer and I'm like yeah she's like
no that's what no this one oh that one's
dead oh that one out of juice that one's
out of commission it's it's so much yeah
it's the and everyone has a different
charger and the charging ports are
always very it's almost like the the
clit the check yeah they're trying to
find the charging porn sex toys
or a guy just tried to find the vagina
hole I feel like guys are always
surprised at how far back yeah it really
goes under there
I used to think girls peed out of the
front like almost like where the dick is
right right yeah where was I wrong yeah
all right y'all
I don't know how to say this but I'm
just gonna say it
guess what I'm up to these days Pat what
do you think I'm up to
are you even being recorded I hope I
hope you're putting your feet up and
relaxing that would be ideal
look Pat I don't have time to put my
feet up just because I'm pregnant I'm
too busy probably suing Akon okay
you know Akon you know him from the
songs that he's had to write where he
apologizes imagine getting to a point in
your career where you're just going
sorry for the things I've done sorry for
all the things I'm gonna imagine
being so a morally it's what is it
morally compromised that you need to
start putting out bops just general
apology just to cover your bases legally
or do damage control so Akon that singer
remember on this podcast we have a very
viral sound on Tick Tock where Miranda
Cosgrove came on and I went what's your
favorite curse word why am I mocking
myself but I did kind of sound like that
uh Miranda Cosgrove brings out the 13
year old and everyone and I was like
what's your favorite curse word and
she's like probably
the curse word that she says and it was
like this big thing Akon takes takes it
makes a song out of it makes all this
money but I own it
what you can't do that you just can't do
that I'm not normally a litigious person
nobody is really until they are until
someone does something so flagrant that
you feel so disrespected and so violated
they just it's too far I don't know what
I'm gonna do yet but Morgan and Morgan
I see the way they operate and it's made
me think you know what maybe it's time I
stand up for myself for once you know
I'm maybe it's because I'm pregnant but
I'm thinking in terms of justice for
once I used to be the person that was
like ah no I'm just gonna let this
person take advantage of me yeah I'm
just gonna let this person walk all over
me yeah no I was at the grocery store
the other day Okay first mistake
and I was in the parking lot there it's
always the woman with the yoga mat it's
always the people that have a yoga mat
and you're like oh they must be like a
relaxed calm person why are you carrying
it around the grocery store why do you
have it on your back
leave it in the car first of all okay
she goes to her it's almost to let
people know like I'm better than you
look at my Periwinkle yoga mat like get
out of my way I'm going to the seeds
section I'm gonna go scoop seeds out of
the plastic it's like that person it's
in a bag already get the one with the
back I don't know
so then she we're kind of you know when
you're just like on the same Journey
with someone in a grocery store like I
couldn't get rid of I couldn't get her
out it was like she was Haunting Me So
then we check out at the same time we'd
go to the our cars at the same time she
doesn't return her cart
and I'm suing just kidding that's not
why uh but that's your first red flag
I'll be in court like she didn't return
her cart you're honor and everyone's
like guilty so she doesn't return her
card she just leaves it out to for who
knows who to get hit by or
or some underpaid person have to go
bring back in and 100 degree weather who
cares not relevant uh and then she gets
in her car starts instagramming who God
knows what about the seeds or nuts that
she just bought and she almost hits like
two people and I'm like watching this
and I'm like if she hits someone I am a
witness like I am I like took my phone
out I was like and then I I almost
caused an accident because I was trying
to film her maybe causing an accident in
case I needed to like testify I think
she was on some edibles or God knows
what
anyway the point is I just watched this
woman almost hit two people she was like
going some crazy way in the in the she
was going against the thing and had this
it was very dramatic okay the point is
I was an eyewitness and I was ready to
deliver Justice okay did you know that
35 of all fatal accidents occur between
6 pm and midnight it was 7 30. boom
people aged 25 to 34 have the highest
amount of drivers involved in car
crashes thanks social media people age
to uh 15 to 24 had the highest rate of
emergency room visits due to car
accidents of all age groups so look if
you're ever injured you can check out
Morgan and Morgan Morgan is America's
largest injury Law Firm they have over
100 offices Nationwide and more than 800
lawyers with over 15 billion dollars
recovered for over 300 000 clients
Morgan Morgan has proven a track record
of fighting to get you full and fair
compensation Morgan Morgan has been
fighting for the people for over 35
years submitting an injury claim with
Morgan and Morgan is so easy
life is hard navigating a grocery store
is hard submitting an injury claim with
Morgan and Morgan is easy if you're ever
injured you can check out Morgan and
Morgan their fee is free unless they win
for more information go to
forthepeople.com Whitney or dial pound
law pound 529 from your cell phone
that's for for the people.com Whitney or
pound 529 from your cell phone this is a
paid advertisement see you soon Akon and
so let me ask you or do you ever feel
threatened by the sex toys no I see it
as an assist that's cool you know I like
it and I want her to get off yeah I just
I just don't my big bottom line with sex
toys is I don't need the veins uh but uh
because you can get extra veiny I
thought it was women like them I know
it's ribbed kind of yeah but I I don't
know did you buy the hook line and
singer the ad campaign of Trojan like
ribbed for her pleasure I thought that
was a good thing I just like I don't
let's not pretend it's a day okay we
don't need to get make it like so
realistic right let's just make it a
weird alien orb yeah you know might as
well put a ward on there
bright purple we don't need to add like
veins
um that's interesting was that did was
that something that you guys like came
about together was that something she
already had like a protocol down before
you met she was always a big vibrating
lady for her and uh which is good
because vibrating lady yeah which she
you know means like she knows her way
around the uh the kitchen there that's
cool because I feel like I spent a lot
of time assuming I was like don't you
know I don't know and guys were like I
don't know and I'm like man am I no all
right let's just let's pretend and then
she hands it to me and I just started
hitting stuff and I'm she's like lower
to the right I'm like oh geez so I'm
learning too I like that I'm all all
about Direction yeah but that's I mean
how could you not be I yeah I know I
find it really annoying like it is funny
though when you're hooking up with
someone for the first time and they just
go into what worked on the previous
version yeah yeah I now know exactly I
know so much about your ex now that's
true you know yeah you like you go right
for the choke and they're like Jesus
Christ that's a big one or the pink the
pink guys will do that when they're
worried I'm gonna talk
um let me but if you're gonna choke you
have to do it right do you know what I
mean yeah just kind of yeah don't make
me act yeah don't make me like
you know like just do it or don't but I
I was dating a guy who is in the medical
profession and one time I kind of like
just sort of encouraged the choking
thing for him to do it and he did it
like like he went like this oh no like
he's trachea like he did it the way like
a doctor would yeah do it
so Dexter so do you think people are
getting choked in the 50s and just
didn't know like that was a thing
they're like well are we weird we choke
I choke you because no one talked about
it no I think they meant it though oh I
think it was real oh got it got it I
guess like women that's just I think
maybe how it was that's a good question
and then also they said sex is way down
like our parents fucked way more than we
fucked it's not wild it's disturbing
yeah I don't I think that we have this
uh exaggerated version of it because we
hear about like polyamory and like and
Tinder I think a lot of people are like
texting but they're not actually hooking
up I think you're right and then porn is
obviously way up yeah hookers are up and
by the way losing the age you lose your
virginity is going up oh dramatically
yeah what were you
[Music]
Louisiana yeah
um and so okay it's all going down
hookers is up hookers is way up because
no one knows how to interact like no guy
has any game or any like social skills
so cool I mean it's like back in the day
right it's like you only were exposed to
like five or six women in your life true
you know what I mean you're next door
yeah and then all of a sudden there was
like all this variety and then I was
like ah I'm gonna hurt people I'm gonna
get a disease yeah it makes when I look
at and maybe this is like a uh
accidental consequence good or bad
whatever of me too where I think a lot
of guys are like uh sex for sports kind
of over right every girl that I kind of
have drunk sex with that could be just a
you know yeah damocally stored hanging
over my head forever why don't I just do
it if I'm gonna have transactional sex
why don't we actually do transactional
yeah that's a good point yeah I won't
get in trouble no bad feeling no bad
blood why not yeah you know what they're
doing they're good at it there's no like
vagueness like no one gets hurt I'm not
against it I think that's cool I think
it's cool too because it like I get that
women are more emotional and all that
but like which is fine but when they act
like they're not that's when it gets
tricky I'm like I'm just like one of the
guys I love fucking I have no feelings
and then you fuck them and they're like
where are you going are you moving here
why do you stop fucking him so good Mark
oh no it's not great I'll tell you
but you know I remember like I don't
remember but like you know years ago
you'd fuck a girl on the road she's like
so are you leaving you're like yeah yeah
I'm in Pittsburgh I live in New York
what am I gonna move here I don't even
know your name do you think I live in
Penguins yeah like what but that
happened you saw my dates on the poster
you know exactly and they but they would
buy into it like whoa where you can't go
I'm like I can't wait to go I mean it
really is tricky because
um yeah you're not just gonna leave me
here that was the plan yeah pretty woman
ruined it for all of us dude I don't I
definitely had that fantasy of like
you're gonna get me out of this town and
take me with you to the big city yeah
you're like my apartment in New York is
smaller than this Pittsburgh hotel room
it's not exactly it's interesting
because I I've definitely tried to have
to be that person before and you're like
oh no I got it and then you have sex
with someone it's just the
neurochemicals like um can explain about
her but yeah but you gotta you gotta
admit that we're wired to get attached
like that which is totally cool it's
just biological but you know you can't
be like no it's no no I brush it right
off but then go nuts when you leave
because is there a way to do it where
there's
um
minimizes that yeah I mean I've known
guys I'm not going to say any names
where they're like this is just for fun
right we're not I don't want a
girlfriend right now I don't want
anything serious like I'm very
attractive you haven't met me yeah that
makes me that makes me like women are
competitive too guys are competitive in
other ways you know what I mean but like
when a guy in my more toxic days Glory
Days if a guy said that I'd be like yeah
you just haven't met me yeah like oh
this is gonna be like I'm level like
this is I don't know Grand Theft Auto
like a higher level like this is just
gonna be a more complicated Rubik's cube
right you know it's almost like I take
it as a challenge yes yes but then when
he still is like all right gotta go then
the shit hits the fan and then I'm like
oh so I'm ugly right right what did you
know you're not ugly I mean I wouldn't
want to have sex with you if you're ugly
I know but I was gonna change your
childhood
I don't know what to tell you I gotta go
the kegels didn't do it you really it's
like God maybe it is the way that we
were programmed of course of like
romantic comedies because every romantic
comedy already always started with a guy
who was like I'm not interested it's
like Vince Vaughn it's Patrick Dempsey
it's whoever like you know I don't I
can't commit and then you know let's be
honest like a hot like a six like you
know a lot of the actresses that were
like in the romantic comedies the reason
we liked him so much is because they
weren't Angelina Jolie right you know
what I mean they were like yeah and
they're like changed him and he's like
he she went to the airport exactly to
meet her yeah well that's your porn yeah
yeah they really are you know where guys
like baby the the mom at the pool will
fuck me and you'll still watch him just
to to masturbate to to how people used
to be able to just go to the gate even
if you weren't flying I'm like ah right
you got the guy with the Boombox Cusack
and you're you're coming it is so wild
to watch old comedies like that and
you'll just like Crocodile Dundee he
runs into the airport past the ticket
encounter to the gate we're like what
crazy Daniel Tosh is a great job how he
likes 911 because he doesn't have to
bring his girlfriend to the gate you
know he's like I'll get you an Uber sir
I can't go
it's so thank God for these terrorists
so wild I know I haven't seen Tosh in a
while yeah where is he I know he's so
funny great comic no he's where I was in
the pandemic yeah I don't know he's um
uh he got he I feel like he does
something very interesting which I think
Jeselnik kind of does this to Ali Wong
maybe I try to think of the people who
I'm like who are the people that like
still like work a lot and but aren't on
podcasts or don't have oh yeah
mullaney's rarely yeah that's true yeah
that's true and you're kind of like does
it add to like a mistake yeah exactly
like are they sick of us exactly are we
spreading ourselves too thin yeah or
have we said these stories over and over
yeah it's a good point yeah like maybe I
don't know maybe there's something to
that well I'd also think there's some
Comics who just aren't cut out for like
they're not talking funny yeah writer
funny yeah I feel like I'm not maybe
sometimes I think it depends on the
chemistry with the person like no you're
good on pods really your podcast gold oh
gosh yeah you're the female Bobby Lee
yeah no but your dick smaller belly at
five months pregnant but Bobby's like
you put them on a pod it's killer and
you are the same way you can talk you
can you got things to say you have
opinions you're realistic well I also
kind of like there when I go to other
people's podcasts I'm kind of like
people are here for the hosts usually
like or the chemistry between yeah and
I'm fine with going I'll go in a
direction that maybe isn't something I
believe just to keep things interesting
that's but that's a good Entertainer you
know whereas other people are like I
don't know about that you're like what
are you thinking they're like ah and
you're like well this is to hit a wall
well because I'm like your fans might
not like me you know what I mean and if
they're just hearing me as a guest on
your podcast I might as well make bring
out a side of you that they don't get to
see a lot that's great maybe that's
interesting but that's more than most
Comics are thinking I think you're going
into it with already like some thought
put into it a plan yeah it is kind of
wild though the idea that like you know
Comics like even when we don't know each
other we do each other's podcasts like
the idea of like you know people I've
talked to that are you know not Comics
which doesn't happen often thank God I'm
no kidding it's just I found that the
the more I go out in the world the more
I just do well with comics of course
normies I I just always feel like I'm
bombing I always feel like I'm crossing
a line I always feel like I'm offending
people or just like saying the wrong
thing I'm with you so hard dude I was in
line at Starbucks and this person was
like oh when he comes how's it going I
was like good dude the aliens man and I
literally just was like let's get into
the air like I want to go so I don't do
small talk I do big talk right away yes
big time Big Talk that's the move yeah
I'm with you Family reunions any kind of
like my wife's family I'm totally
filtered freaking out I'm like shaking
inside don't say this don't say that
it's got me in trouble I've been fired
anytime I've been hired as like to be me
and not a comedy setting I've blown it I
did a gig somebody saw me at the seller
and they're like we're hosting a thing
for AOL I don't know if I'm supposed to
say that but they're like it's a
Halloween show and there'll be a costume
contest bobbing for apples the whole
thing and we want you to host it and you
showed up in blackface close
they were like we want we like how
you're edgy you kind of walk that line
we like that and I was like oh great and
so the first we prepared all week we
wrote jokes we did this we did that I'm
hosting the costume contest
Catwoman walks on hot lady you know
we're like uh full audience big big
production I got paid a ton of money
she's got a big Whip and a cat outfit
she's super hot and I was like yeah look
at Catwoman yeah looking good whatever
she leaves and an African queen walks on
and I went hey watch that whip around
the African and the cameras went
and like wilted and uh the whole room
felt weird the black women didn't give a
shit but everybody freaked out then I
went on to my next segment which was I
was wearing drag and I got fired in drag
I had a full wig on I had these big
eyelashes I had a dress on and heels and
makeup now you know what it's like to be
a woman in the workforce you immediately
fired it sucked and I blew the CEO but
uh but they were like we gotta talk and
I was like huh I remember looking over
with some heavy lashes and they were
like you gotta go the agent the boss
women aren't funny
you were so much funnier when you were a
man yeah but they were like be edgy I
was like what's more what's that that's
edgy the whip can I read you some jokes
that I did at a corporate event recently
oh I can't wait that went so South oh I
love it so corporate events really make
you realize that like you're we're
different we're clowns right we're
Carney Folk
to that like when you do when you're
doing a show for your the comedy fans
that show up the best feeling in the
world when you get hired for a corporate
gig you know Oreo stockholders meaning
whatever right you're basically nothing
against piano players and at a lounge
but like you're just the piano player in
the background it's like they maybe want
to get photos with you but like they
don't respect you in any capacity right
and um okay I'd have to find this
because I wrote all these Rose jokes uh
for okay here we go
here for this um oh roasting is never
good
[Music]
and every year it's gotten worse and
worse like roasting used to be you could
say anything to the head of the company
you cheat on your wife your scumbag and
now it's all of a sudden really dicey
yep they send like the list of the
people that are gonna be there blah blah
blah and I get there this year and I
guess there's a lot of like there's a
big Saudi presence this year okay oh I
know this joke this went around the
scene oh really yeah this is great I'll
keep going
because I ran it by a couple of good
jokes afterwards well it was a I mean I
had many it went and I the harder I Bond
the harder I just went into it because I
just I just was just like oh hey Saudis
why is everyone so scared I'm gonna make
fun of you are you trans
you guys the man over there wear dresses
because it's their religion not because
it's their truth
nice uh is getting a chuckle a tee hee
uh-huh the Saudis actually laugh that's
not always the way of course yeah and
then everybody else I guess that's
scared of them you know they're more
worried sure Saudis you guys are
gentlemen at least you wait to die
before you have sex with virgins oh
great line I'm I've been in the Middle
East very many times I was never scared
the only time I've ever been scared of
Saudis is one from the back I thought he
was a priest
uh and then hold on I did oh because it
was also a lot of like really successful
like Tech kind of people and I was like
you guys we honestly have more in common
with the Saudis than we don't I mean
half the people in this room just moved
to a desert where women have no rights
it's called Texas oh nice so it was like
kind of about everyone that's when
things got a little bit South and maybe
this is the joke that maybe you've heard
uh look a strong partnership between
Saudi and America is long overdue the
911 thing was a setback I'm not gonna
lie it really hurt our country because
it made a comedian named Pete Davidson
famous oh and we will never forget oh
that's a great thing you did that so it
was Alex you know and it just got worse
and worse and it just was like
you know it was just frustrating because
it's like they're like come do your job
and then but don't do it like that yeah
but that's real comedy you're doing real
comedy in a corporate I had a similar
thing I did a gigging Toronto guy met me
he's like I'll buy you dinner first then
we'll go he's like I'm a huge fan can
you tell this joke can you tell that
joke I was like this is a lot I was like
quoting my jokes to me he loves this
joke so it's like a 60-person room all
these millionaire real estate guys yeah
and I'm up there the bike sucks all that
shit the sound is always awful every
time which always makes you lose your
power you may lose respect for you
that's that's half the problem with
corporate gigs 100 I'm doing a lot of
this you're in some restaurant yeah it
was in the top floor of a restaurant and
they're kind of like all right they're
ready they're nice guys they're like oh
we want some laughs they're all drinking
and the guy who booked me is in the
front row going okay baby here we go
like you got this and by the way you're
a bunch of people in suits and you don't
know who is the
the branch manager and who is the CEO
yes so so you might just go hey this
asshole and that's the scene you're like
yeah that too so I go all right I try
some jokes they're all kind of not doing
great and then I go well fuck it let me
go into the ones that he likes just
because those will be obviously a
foolproof and they're all bombing and so
I'm looking at the guy he's going
I'm telling the jokes that you like and
they're still bombing
and it was it was I did an hour and 20
of zero laughs because I kept trying to
get out of it he's like come on here it
comes as if I'm like not if I'm not
telling him right or something but it
was good no your staff is broken yes
they don't care yeah he's doing this to
me and you're like fix the venue yeah
there's no speakers right right God and
it's like I find myself and then you
know and this is what I would say about
people who are like what is up with JLo
having a rider where she needs 12
candles and 42 Skittles that are blue
and you're like a lot of times when your
Rider like leaks or someone's like oh
this person's such an asshole for having
such a specific Rider a lot of times
it's to prevent stuff like this you know
it's like the famous Green Day story of
they say we want a bowl of green M M's
and if they show up and the green M Ms
are there they know everything else is
going to be on point exactly you know so
it's like there's times where it's like
you can have the most detailed Rider and
like I know all the things are gonna go
wrong at this and then you get there and
it's like Community Theater production
where you're talking into you know the
PlayStation controller that sunk the
Seagate you know and you're like or
there's like no microphone at all and
you're like this is a goddamn nightmare
exactly exactly I ran out of there I was
so embarrassed ah
a couple of those I feel like this year
yeah and I feel like we were texting
about this earlier we didn't get less
funny exactly you guys got Lamer yes
it's like my thing with liberals like
like I think does Bill Maher say this
like I I didn't change yeah you guys
moved so far to the left right that I'm
now moderate yes exactly exactly and the
weird thing is people come up to you
after like I liked it you know about
these stiffs and I'm like you're a pussy
you could have laughed but whatever
because when you're walking into like a
workplace that you never know like they
can only laugh at their boss laughs
there's an HR person there exactly
usually those things the first thing
I'll do is like who's the HR person yeah
it's we know exactly who it is it's
always Pam whatever it's always some
woman in like a cat shirt and you're
like everything although I kind of am
jealous of HR people I feel like HR
people get to hear all the best jokes
now oh that's a great point I feel like
HR people just go through their email
and they're just like and by by the way
HR I've had sex with a couple HR women
freaks freaks HR women are are whores
Freaks and sluts it's it's because they
gotta get it out you know they're pent
up
from all the sexual harassment claims
stay here all day here is like sex
stories all day first he bent me over on
the desk and she's like oh God I gotta
go fuck a comedian in Poughkeepsie how
do you meet the HR people well they come
to comedy shows I've noticed because I
think they're like that's true you know
because I gotta I gotta hear a joke
because it's all serious at the office
that every time I do
I do it where I bring up an HR person
and um I'm now realizing usually two or
three people are like I'm in HR or maybe
that's just like everyone's in HR now
because it's the only job it's the only
job that's half of every company now
yeah exactly because you know every
company's terrified so like get another
HR person here just so we look on the up
and up so ridiculous I know um how did
you meet your wife uh at a comedy show
actually cool she was on a date with a a
guy she hated and I had a decent set and
then she DM me
I love that yeah I got lucky and she
quoted one of my bits in the DM and I
said let's get a drink
comedy yeah and how long ago was that
seven years whoa three years yeah that
is wild we dated for a while then you
know she cried so I proposed and then uh
yeah the rest is history were you like
thinking about proposing did it have to
come to uh they got pretty serious it
got pretty it came to a head you know
um but you know she wanted it really bad
and uh yeah I get it now because once
you once you're married like everything
chills you know there's probably
something nice about it's like getting
tenure at a university exactly exactly
the contract is signed yes we're all
good and I I made a lot of like
hey I need if we're gonna get married I
need this this and this and she was like
all good I'm all about just up front
getting up from and women are the most
least upfront people you know it's all
Vibes you know why didn't you hit me on
me I'm like I didn't know and you're
like oh come on I was putting it out
there I'm like I had no idea I know but
again I feel like I don't know I've been
accused so much of like being
emasculating or being like aggressive
and like I feel like I have to be like
all like demure and and if I'm too
forward it's like unattractive
or something no dike it up you go nuts I
hate these guys who say that they're
fucking pussies okay so tell me okay so
you just had special come out how do you
feel did it fix everything no are you
healed no but now it's a bittersweet
because it did pretty well we were in
the top ten for a while and Netflix gave
me the nice happy email we're very happy
with this so that's kind of weird
parental hole they're filling but you're
happy you're not very happy great yeah
but then you got the agents who are like
special doing great let's get you back
on the road you're like I have no
material I have no material yeah really
but we want the money yeah yeah so I'm
out there just shucking and driving good
I mean I find though sometimes like
giving yourself like I have three months
to write an hour like you'll do it in
three months that's true I feel like we
kind of have this thing based on the
fact that like okay you used to do like
our heroes the people that we looked up
to they did like it had a new hour every
year so like I guess it must take a year
to write an hour right you know and I'm
not saying it's gonna be perfect at the
thing that you shoot on your next thing
but when I gave myself three months like
I did it really yeah wow I mean it
wasn't perfect sure you know and you had
a full hour and I also think like I
don't know just don't quote me on this
if like I'm end up being wrong but I've
been noticing that like people coming to
shows now at least people that are
coming to see you they know you they
listen to you on Rogan they listen to
you on your um podcast with Sam like
yeah
I don't think they're always coming for
Perfection I think you're right they
want you yeah like sometimes like
something you're like well that joke
didn't quite work yeah and then they see
later that you changed it based on the
the fact that it didn't do so great in
St Louis and then you're like thanks for
helping me with that St Louis like it
wasn't quite there yet like so true I
used to wait till something was so
perfect and Polished and lockstep to go
out and I think it now just because of
how much people see us not being like
that it feels like overly presentational
yeah and kind of corny yeah good point
you know so it's like I'm not saying
like be sloppy I'm not like people are
paying money like I'm obviously putting
a lot of work but the idea that
something's not totally fine-tuned yet I
think there's something kind of I think
there's something special about that and
they like being part of the process all
these Reddit nerds are like I saw him
work that out and yeah totally like I
got to see
a woman joke do okay yeah yeah
on that I think there's something too
when you're up against it in this giant
theater of 1500 people and you kind of
have a happy day it pulls something out
of you yeah that doesn't happen just on
the paper at the hotel room a little
pressure is good A little pressure good
it's terrifying and you'd probably pick
to not have it you choose to not go
through it but if you do go through it
something might happen that's pretty
because I I think I'm guessing um uh no
offense but I feel like we're kind of
similar in the way that we like like
write yeah you know and like it's
there's a surgical nature to it and
there's like you know like do you sit
down write stuff out yeah me too that's
so funny that you're so down yourself
you might be like me no offense yeah no
I just didn't want to let you know no I
don't give a shit I was gonna
self-deprecate I guess but um but yeah
but I fully like write things out and go
like let me change this way I already
use that word oh yeah you know that was
one of the biggest knocks because you
know you read some of the reviews and
one guy was like it's funny but it felt
like AI stand up because it was so boom
boom like every hand movement I have
down and I was like uh yeah that's he
got me there
that's pretty good because I when it
hurts like that you're like yeah that's
probably truth to that so that I I
absorbed it and now when I'm up there I
try to be looser
just use the use it then just like take
it you know I think that to get shamed
or feel bad about being polished I think
it's like also I think part of the
reason you know I really enjoy you is
because I'm like this just feels like
it's the best of like super modern but
also feels like classic like the
stand-up I fell in love with you know
yeah same jokes jokes jokes I feel safe
with this person like I know like I've
fallen into a rhythm there's like a
Harmony to it and I also think there's
something really cool about being like
that's a Mark Norman joke like oh I love
that I think that's like the best
feeling when someone's like ah this is
such a you joke like you have such a
specific style
yeah I'd rather that than just like be
interchangeable with all a lot of comics
that are just kind of conversational
completely agree completely agree like
you could do that with a norm joke or a
Joan Rivers Joe like that is so Joan
Rivers or so Rodney yeah totally and I
like the way that like I mean I don't
know I think not that I'm trying to
write for the way stand up is consumed
but sometimes you have to think like
that you know yeah I was like okay
how can I break up this hour into 60
second Clips yes you know what I mean
because that might be how it's consumed
at the end of the day yeah of course and
I think those do better and I think I
tend to write short so do you like we go
set up punch set up punch set up punch
and our fan base probably like has been
living on Twitter the past 15 years
which is like set a punch you know
shorts Tick Tock yeah and like I loved
Dimitri Martin and Zach Galifianakis and
Mitch Hedberg and like I and jezzled
like I I love that I love being able to
like here's a setup here's a punch like
this is like I just love the art of that
making that surprise yes yeah it's like
a little magic trick verbally it's such
a magic trick and also I think it's
actually harder when you do it the way
completely agree the way that you do it
because it's like you know I'm gonna
have a banger yeah now I have to trick
you into not knowing how I'm gonna do it
can I say tell you a norm story really
quick and then I'll let you go I know
yeah that's my face um he because it's
kind of like it's it makes you to kind
of kin in a way that is not
um
okay so we're in the Roseanne writers
room this is for the first season of
Roseanne which I um eped and uh I was
like we gotta have Norm he could only he
did one day a week and came in that's
hilarious and yeah and uh he came in one
day a week and was just the best and
he pitched this joke because you know
Roseanne what I loved about it and I
think what everyone loved about it is
that it was like equally like
hilariously funny but also there was
Pathos and you know it was like
heartbreaking and there were real
stories and you know so there were some
writers in there that were real like
kind of drama writers that wanted to get
to the emotion of the scene and the
relationships and then there was you
know Wanda Sykes and Norm Macdonald and
Morgan Murphy and you know and like the
joke people yeah
so Norm pitched you know uh so this is
one writer who she's great but she was
you know she was like she's always like
the relationship and like would she
really say that and what's like the
emotional truth of the scene and he was
just kind of like oh what if what if he
says you know he says this yeah and she
was like yeah but like like why like why
would she say that right there and he
just went because comedy
uh yes I love it and obviously not like
you would never know he said that he
would never know you said it right it's
like so funny wow wow that's That's
Heavy yeah that's a great story do you
um feel like there's anything to be
worried about on the YouTube front with
podcasts though that's what makes me
nervous just when I was like it's fine
the network TV's going away like we have
YouTube and now I feel like YouTube that
is scary you can't do anything have you
ever had any stuff taken down we've had
demonetizing because we said you know
queef too many times in the first minute
or whatever but maybe that's something
you should learn but like this I had all
these horrific jokes and they let them
stay together like no notes all they
said was maybe don't do covet stuff
because it's kind of over and I said
like can you please do trans jokes that
went great for Chappelle special number
one special ever that's true so that was
shocking and then you hear about YouTube
like taking the Roseanne uh Theo episode
you're like oh shit has it flipped no
it's like you can't say Nazi you can't
say Hitler you get Margie Taylor green Q
Anon like they just have these like
there's just Bots just going through it
and it just feels like I mean we've had
a bunch of them be age restricted
demonetized and you're kind of like oh
or the days of comedians being able to
say whatever they want on YouTube are
they over yeah man I wonder if pods will
go but then like Spotify stuck with
Rogan so I don't know who knows anymore
yeah it's kind of picking and choosing
now what else what else uh well you know
I think I think I do think we're coming
out of the whole thing doesn't feel like
we're kind of coming out of this scary
time a little which one like just the
censoring and the friends getting in
trouble and stuff is that it well I
guess lizzo just went through it yeah
they moved on to women yeah they
realized women are toxic too right right
well that's equality I feel like the
days of like being casual around 22 year
olds is over okay I feel like people
just it's going to be survival of the
people that hire the oldest employees
right you know or the P you know what I
mean this whole thing of like I'm gonna
hire this 22 year old who has Twitter
and has learned that the way to get
ahead is to cancel their boss or snitch
on their boss instead of just try to
learn from them or like I don't know
have a private conversation first yes
or just be like this might not be the
right job for me I don't know but like I
think that makes you feel better
DiCaprio because that's all he's fucking
is women that age you know so you're
like boy you must have to not talk about
anything yeah I mean I just I I when I
think about employees now I'm kind of
like is this the person that came up you
know reading the meme if you don't start
your own dream you're going to be
building someone else's like yeah maybe
you should be doing that in your 20s
yeah maybe you should be learning and
developing skills and eating shit no one
wants to eat shit anymore no I want to
eat shit no no back to the Lobster
that's it exactly like I had to eat so
much shit like I mean when I was a
writer on last call with Carson Daly
like it was just I wasn't like how do I
get rid of this person if I don't like
the way I'm being treated I'm like how
do I even know how I'm supposed to be
being treated yeah no are they gonna get
rid of me that was my big fear in the uh
crazy exactly and the crazier thing to
me is that I'm like I'm not saying don't
stand up to someone who's being abusive
I wasn't there I mean I don't know I
heard the list of allegations and
they're like she locked me in a room
that's not a feature on a door but okay
um like in what world like yeah so um or
like she took me to a strip club like in
Amsterdam yeah she's toxic like what
kind of well you're what kind of person
can't say no thanks I'm gonna stay in
exactly and it's the music world it's
rock star shit like I thought that was
part of the fun go be an accountant yeah
I know I'm like I cannot think of a more
fun job yeah like I'm traveling the
world with a pop star who's world famous
so it seems I mean you signed up for it
there's a million people would love that
gig yeah I guess you know what but again
we don't know what happened and we don't
know what happened yeah but I don't know
yeah
after reading the allegations I should
know that should be a an emoji yeah yeah
we have this guy
yeah
we're like these girls are liars
that's what I'm saying like yeah take it
with a grain of salt
I'm not whoever's side wins well I think
it's just kind of like an Ellen thing
like all right to be that big to be that
powerful you got to be a cunt you know
you gotta crack the whip a little bit I
think people don't like getting the whip
cracked yeah
but like I
don't know I just think it's it's a the
Darwinism of if you know people came up
going
if I'm uncomfortable that person
deserves yes to go away forever is wild
to me and I think we just have to go
like you know I was just interviewing
for someone for something I was like why
can't we don't talk enough we talk about
sexism we talk about we don't talk about
ageism you know I'm like why when I'm
looking for someone in an assistant
position or a producer said why do I go
to 21 year olds it's a great point
because in my head I'm like I want to
make sure they know how to use tick tock
in this it's like why wouldn't someone
in their 40s know how to do that why
can't I hire some 48 year old bitch
named Linda who doesn't give a shit
exactly you know what I mean two kids as
long as I want yeah
yeah exactly someone not knowing how to
how to use is why I would
how we get it out somewhere like Cosby
it all went to the bedroom yeah like hey
scared of women don't get a don't piss
them off don't hug them too long and
then it's like choke me spit on me spit
my mouth call me a retard whatever it is
it just came out there it's this weird
thing now where if you're my employer
you're expected to make my dreams come
true yeah which is kind of this new
thing and we're so scared that you're
gonna accuse us of being toxic that we
can just do it of course and then we're
just enabling and giving you a very
inaccurate sense of of the world of what
the world is it's actually being a
terrible boss yeah the way I can be the
best Mentor is going like no if you're
done at six I'm done at six yeah well
it's the same with a parent if you get
to give the kid everything they want
yeah the kid's fucked yeah and you think
you heard now I heard California's black
kids are getting easier math tests
because they weren't that is so racist I
mean I know it's horrible and you're
like I know you're trying to do good and
you think you're helping but that's
gonna fuck them for longer
Untouchable topic but I'm like I think
this is wrong but you guys think it's
good because it's a quick fix but a
quick fix is the worst solution yeah you
know I mean at least give the girls
easier amount of time
does it feel like a racial thing this
feels like a gender thing right well
look at the Asians they're getting
kicked out of Harvard for doing too well
it is what it is yeah
we thrive in a in a toxic work
environment right right
I love you dude good pod good pod yes we
got a lot out can you go do some spots
yeah I'm a psycho nah that no you're not
okay thank you can I tell you uh Louis
CK last thing since we're doing um uh
things Louie told us I remember I
because so many people pathologized me
for I would when I started I'm doing
five spots a night yeah Comedy Store
Laugh Factory Hermosa uh Ice House
backed it up and one time I uh Louis was
outside the Improv and um I we were like
talked for a second and I was like I
gotta go I gotta head to Hermosa I'm
doing another spot tonight I know I'm
I'm like a psycho and he was like no
that's what it takes ah and it was so
matter of fact the way that he said it
was like it changed it totally
dissipated all my shame and
embarrassment about it because other
Comics want to be like oh you're gonna
go to another song all the time and also
I like it yeah I like doing the spots I
like doing this for a living yeah they
want to put it on like you're some
workaholic weirdo you're trying to be
better than everybody I'm like I enjoy
it yeah I want to go get up again I am
these very awkwardly all right I love
you guys don't write elephant foreign
[Music]
foreign
[Applause]